blake griffin misses that one
[Applause]
[Music]
james spins kicks it out westbrook
right back into james
[Music]
[Applause]
and on to the free-throw line where he's
overall 12 points
well they switched the pick and roll
and then james just discards
bruce brown
and an easy layup off a nice pass
by westbrook
lebron james will turn 37 years old
this coming thursday
and when you think about it 37
19th year in the
now he is the all-time leading scorer on
christmas
and the numbers he's putting up and i
say 19th year he added another couple of
years of all the playoff games the
numbers he's putting up right now this
this last 12-13 game surge it's
extraordinary
his whole career has been extraordinary
the way his sustained greatness
i'm sure there are some things that
stanley johnson
runs to the other end
just call for a foul
that's going to be the 15 pound
[Music]
[Applause]
well that's good hands
with some contact
[Applause]
the left arm around the waist made it
tough yeah oh you guys got to stop you
know what i like that was a terrible
inbound pass a terrible steal and a good
steal i'm with you i played 17 years
with the guys i'm around my waist
[Applause]